so he's only going to do all
quadrilaterals share as it were some DNA
which is that they all have four sides
you're straight four angles that kind of
thing okay so what we're gonna do is try
and tease out the relationships between
these because in the textbook what
you'll find is a list of shapes okay but
that list is just kind of like here's a
random grab bag of things that have
nothing necessarily to do with each
other
okay Jake have you pay attention thank
you
so what we're going to begin with up the
top of the family tree is kind of like
the big great-grandfather of and
everything which is just a four-sided
polygon that's as basic as you can be
and still be a quadrilateral okay and
what I'm going to show you is the
descendants of this guy as we add more
and more specific features or
characteristics okay so the first thing
we're going to do is that if we take our
four-sided polygon and we make a pair of
sides parallel parallel sides just one
pair so I'm gonna say parallel sides
there are two of them okay if you have a
four-sided polygon and there's one pair
of parallel sides there's two sides that
are parallel what kind of shape you have
it's a trapezium very good let's label
that in trapeze you like so and so this
shape you can see is more special than
this one it's got this characteristic in
it okay so it's a trapezium but we can
add more features and make things more
specific okay so for example if I go to
the trapezium and I add another pair of
parallel sides now think think carefully
so now I don't have to I've got two
pairs or four right this is the shape we
created before right the inside shape
this has got so many parallel sides it's
called a parallelogram
by the way a parallelogram is a really
commonly misspelled word it's really not
that hard right the word parallel and
then you say Oh Graham that's it if you
can
parallel then refer back to your points
okay I love a good okay now I'm now
going to hand it over to you for a
second and ask you we're going down this
tree right if you take a parallelogram
let's add some features to this what
kinds of features could we add to this
to make it a more specific kind of shape
because you know all kinds of shapes
yeah what we add okay if we take our
parallelogram in fact if we just add a
single right angle I want you to picture
right here's a parallelogram right pick
an angle any angle say it say this one
in the corner okay what would I do to
this shape to turn that angle into a
right angle as Kate suggests we did kind
of you kind of lean it over wouldn't you
sort of like turn it and pull it that
way right well as you do so do you
notice this becomes a right angle but so
does everything else do you notice that
so if what we put in here is one right
angle okay all of the angles become
right angles right which is why we
literally call this shape right angle
except we call it in Latin the the Latin
phrase for right is wrecked
as in like correct or when something is
wonky and you rectify it rectangle
literally means right angle not get
wrecked
so maybe you should okay so that's fine
what else could we do what else could we
do let's keep going from the rectangle
can you make the rectangle more special
what could you do to an area okay so see
how we've got parallel sides up here's
that's about the direction of the sides
but Aaron's making a suggestion about
the length of the side so let's add in
equal sides equal sides what does this
create it's a square
now the square is the most special of
all of the quadrilaterals so that's why
you can see I've drawn it at the bottom
there's there's no more that we can add
to make it more super special that's it
okay and what I want you to point out
before we finish this diagram because
not complete yet every shape down here
carries with it all of the properties
above right that's that's why it's a
family tree so for example see the
square it's got right angles yeah it
also has two pairs of parallel sides
does that make sense we're gonna
rectangle it's got everything above it
it's got one pair of parallel sides
doesn't it in fact it's got two does
that make sense so every square is also
a rectangle every rectangle is also a
parallelogram every parallelogram is
also a trapezium you get the idea
okay now this diagram is um I can't go
any further
but there are some shapes missing there
are shapes you know that aren't on here
what's missing okay so I heard rhombus
now just pause for a minute put your pen
down and actually think those shout it
out or want you to think the rhombus
belongs in this family truth the
question is where does it belong
remember if I put something lower that
means it has all the properties of all
the shapes above it okay so where would
it fit to place the rhombus what do you
think Jacob where would you put it
Jacob suggested to put the rhombus off
the parallelogram now what would we do
to a parallelogram to turn it into a
rhombus it's actually already on the
board look closely
a rhombus is a parallelogram with equal
sides
right and what's really nice about this
this is you can see the relationships
now just like we're from parallelogram
to rhombus Jacob nailed it in 1 we could
go from rhombus to Square think
carefully what would we add a right
angle right can you picture look here's
my arm here's my parallelogram let's
turn this into a rhombus so he's Aramis
all the sides are equal it's a square
that's kind of been pushed over hasn't
it
as soon as you add the right angle it
turns it into a square okay now this is
looking pretty good but it's still
missing something there's a shape and
someone did say before a kite okay now
think again again I want you to pause
and think where would the kite below
where's the place that makes the most
sense hmm now remember I said to you
before for instance see this squares on
the water so every square is a rhombus
everyone misses a parallelogram oh no no
no not now can I say that M every cut
every kite can I say I'll make an easy
one is every kind of rectangle no
clearly not okay
like let's just draw one for the sake of
it so he's a kite okay is it so this is
too far down is every kind of
parallelogram doesn't mm but those don't
pan out of me okay so that's no good is
every kite a trapezium
because look have a look at the sides I
don't think any of them necessarily have
to be parallel does that make sense
they widow monkey so if the kite doesn't
come from here which is already second
from the top where's the kite gonna come
from and it's on its own bridge it's got
to come from here does that make sense
you see other fellows so let's check it
over here it's separate the kite a bit
of a weirdo okay okay
all along here the branches indicate
what we have to add to the shape to make
it such in such a shape so you've got a
quadrilateral what do you add to the
quadrilateral to make it a kite think
carefully what is it that makes this
shape what it is now this is actually
very tricky and we're gonna dig deeper
into this I'll save you a bit of time
here's what makes a kind of kind this
those two sides those besides that's
what makes it quiet okay
so therefore see how down here we've got
all the equal sides right or for suppose
we could put four up here I've got two
pairs of equal sides and they don't have
to be equal to each other which actually
tells you even though it's up there
seemingly off on its own I'm gonna pick
up a new color now the kite actually is
related to someone else on this diagram
and I just kind of highlighted it for
you just now right see how it's about
equal sides so equal sides so what it's
closely not closely what it's distantly
related to is the rhombus right how
would you turn a kite into a rhombus
yeah see how these are equal to each
other we'll just make these equal to
each other
and bam you there okay so four equal
sides
something like that okay all right now
underneath or beside your family tree is
it finished
what do you think
is a square also a client let's think
about that question yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's a good question what makes it kind
of kite what makes a kind of kite to
pairs of equal sides does a square have
two pairs of equal sides answer yes it
does
and in fact I've seen Square klutz
before they're not very comment but yeah
it's a kite it's a weed kite but it is
are there any kinds of shapes we're
missing I will tell you there's a weird
one which doesn't come up very much it's
very weird so you might not have even
heard it so I'm going to put it in
another color okay so this is super
weird that's why I'm putting it off on
the side it's easiest for me rather to
describe it I'm gonna draw it for you
okay so what does isosceles mean for
triangles suicides are the same in an
isosceles trapezium you've got two sides
of the same I don't have to see this
over here that's a bad example sorry see
that that's a trapezium isn't it but see
these sides then they're not matched up
at all they don't have to do anything
with each other but this guy you see how
it's like nice it's balanced it's
symmetrical that makes it
isosceles very uncommon but um now the
family tree is completely okay